succession has finally come to an end
and while fans may still be reeling from
those final 20 minutes the main cast
have some opinions of their own HBO's
critically acclaimed drama aired its
final episode this past Sunday leaving
viewers with plenty to talk about in its
wake from setting up a powerful future
for Tom wamsganz to effectively blowing
up the relationship between siblings
shiv Roman and Kendall Roy the
succession series finale wipes out the
show's status quo in a number of key
ways I'm telling you this because I I
know it okay
we're nothing
and it's not just the fans who have felt
the need to share their thoughts on this
eventual final episode Entertainment
Tonight published a piece containing
several actors thoughts about the show's
ending Roman Roy ends his journey
sipping on a Martini in a hotel bar just
minutes after hitting his brother with
some pretty brutal truths and Kieran
Culkin says he thinks the succession
finale leaves Rome's future
appropriately open-ended he said for
Roman it feels very much the same
nothing's wrapped up in a pretty little
bow there's more life that carries on
after the episode ends Nicholas Braun
meanwhile told the outlet that he was
aware of how certain storylines were
going to play out in the finale ahead of
time he said when I read it I just
thought it's just like a perfect ending
I think all of us were very moved by and
excited to give it to the fans well I'd
like to say to the fans thank you so
much for getting so invested in our show
Kieran Culkin and Nicholas Braun weren't
the only cast members who discussed the
finale of succession either Jay Smith
Cameron for instance was quick to note
that her character Jerry doesn't get
much of an ending in the final episode
Tom suggests that he intends to keep her
on at waystar but that's more or less it
Smith Cameron said I feel like things
don't really wrap up for my character in
the world of succession where Jerry sort
of fits in and so many other characters
fit in it could be ongoing Culkin
notably echoed his co-star's thoughts
revealing that he'd think succession
could have continued after the events of
its series finale he said we read the
table draft for the last episode and
then Jesse Armstrong told us that it's
the end of the show it's one of those
instances where if he said there's going
to be a season five right after that it
made sense too it could have gone more
and I feel like in the way that we end
it feels sort of like there still could
be more but I think it's also a
satisfying end Alan Ruck meanwhile told
E.T that reflecting on his feelings
about the finale he ultimately feels
grateful for his succession gank he said
I Won't Say I'm happy but I'm really
glad that I was a part of it and America
be afraid
be warned
for the con heads are coming
thank you God bless America
in other words it sounds like Ruck is
feeling the exact same mix of sadness
and gratitude that hit many succession
fans after reaching the series final
episodes plenty of viewers after all
didn't want to see succession end this
year still at least the show's cast and
crew stuck the landing and it's nice to
know that the ending resonated so widely
including with some of the very people
who helped bring the show to life
everybody kind of you know burst into
tears big giant hug of I don't know how
many people just kind of like this
cluster hug